originally Dylan field and Evan Wallace
started building their design startup
figma as a challenge to Adobe Photoshop
Adobe ended up making the two
co-founders billionaires after
announcing it would acquire figma for 20
billion dollars in a cash and shares
deal that figure doubles the valuation
that the San francisco-based startup
landed last June when it raised 200
million dollars from investors including
durable capital and Morgan Stanley
Forbes estimates field and Wallace each
have a 10 stake in figma that would now
be valued at two billion dollars the
company has been branded the Google docs
for designers with a loyal user base in
the millions paying between 12 to 45
dollars per editor for its digital
whiteboard product figma's success
reflects how important design function
and Aesthetics have become for apps
websites and other user interfaces
across all Industries if you want to
have software that's really good and
people love you have to make sure that
software is something that is really
well designed otherwise you will be
displaced
and I think every incumbent over the
last 10 years has woken over to this and
design has really become an arms race
and people are hiring designers at a
faster rate than ever
this acquisition by Adobe follows
another major takeover last year of the
collaborative video editing and review
software maker frame IO for 1.2 billion
dollars Adobe forecast figma will double
its annual recurring Revenue to 400
million dollars in 2022. in 2020 Forbes
reported that the company made 75
million in Revenue the deal between
Adobe and figma is set to close in 2023
and field will stay on as CEO